rook wants to push to the Thunder Spain  [Applause]  chicas ships  with a smile himself every now and then  a play happens at the ball game he just  say I can't wait to see the replay on  now and that was that play right here by  Russell Westbrook as he was slicing and  dicing it any did a little spin cycle  and found his favorite target where he's  dumped over 60% of his assists this year  Stephen Adams  you see Westbrook located wanted to  write your Stephen Adams who's going to  be on the floor it's over the last  couple of possessions what a fish how  about the Shamgar believe let's start  the beginning so fat  what's the sambar blue right there  before we did the spin nice most spin a  bit older